kelly clarkson welcomed country
superstar garth brooks to her daytime
talk show on monday
where she revealed one of his biggest
hits to date has helped her cope with
her split
from brandon blackstock fans were
shocked back in june when the singer
filed for divorce from her husband of
nearly seven years
but during her socially distanced chat
with garth kelly admitted the dance
has been a light for her in a very dark
time
okay so i'm going through divorce and
and there's been like a lot of
i don't know like books and people
always give you stuff to like help
especially when you have kids and stuff
and i know that you've been divorced as
well and it was like
man there's so much like shame and guilt
and everybody kind of sends you stuff
and i was like
i don't know just kind of working
through it and i couldn't
i couldn't quite nail down like the
feeling i kid you not
i was listening to to my playlist
and the dance came on and i was like no
that's the thing
the american idol alum also told garth
she was inspired to write her
own song inspired by the theme of his
1989 hit which will be featured on her
next album
so i literally it's not like your song
like a ripoff
but it's i literally wrote this whole
thing like therapeutically for me and
it's actually on my next album and
it's um the whole like kind of
come around like the little tag part is
like um even um even though my heart is
broken
um it was worth the dance anyway
and it's like this whole thing but it i
was like i never
i think what's interesting about it is i
sang that song from childhood and i
it never hit me that's a great song
right there oh my god
that's a character of a great song and
to
no surprise kelly was quite excited to
join garth
in singing the mega hit on her show
looking
back oh
quit don't do that
like i can't believe my life
like my april beck and mary mcconnell
all my friends from childhood hate me
right now
i'm so sorry april she's the one that
introduced you to me
and i'm like i feel like i'm stealing
her moment
and now i'm glad i
didn't know the way it
all wouldn't the way it all
wouldn't go